Okay.
We should be live here.
Good morning, folks.
Is there a way to do default category in
Twitch?
It'd be nice if you could change the
default category. I'll change it to um
games and uh was it software?
Software and game development.
I don't think there is a way to um
default
uh to default it though.
Good enough for now. We'll switch the
screen over in just a second.
Hey, Jess.
All right, so let's go over the uh the
thing for today. Um we got a whole bunch
of really weird
really weird experiment results.
Yeah, this doesn't make any sense to me
that this works with no prioritization,
right?
Okay, wait a second. It didn't work with
no prioritization before because there
was a bug with beta at zero.
that prioritization doesn't do anything?
That seems wrong.
This is applying correctly, right?
Like if I just do um
This is going to be a way bigger policy,
right?
Yeah.
This is a way bigger policy.
Yeah, so something is very odd then that
we're seeing
prioritized replay not make any
difference whatsoever.
That should make quite a strong
difference, I would imagine.
If prioritization is not doing anything,
then there's like
that's a much bigger concern.
Cuz essentially
the state set work is going to be a
stronger version of this.
I remember I ran quite extensive
experiments though that this made a huge
difference.
A tragic. No, I don't think it's tragic
just because in my mind
like the this technique
the idea behind it is solid enough that
I like I'd be shocked if this doesn't
work.
It does look like we have this working
with no
prioritization of the replay though.
And actually adding this prioritization
without the correction messes it up.
Today's going to be a lot of thinking
and running relatively short little
experiments.
I do like the uh the maze benchmark
though from before.
Hello, Tim.
Welcome.
Hey, Tim. Can you do me a favor when you
get a chance? Just when you happen to
have
um like don't kill any active runs,
but if you happen to get like a good set
of hypers on Sokoban,
if you could just set uh prio beta to
one and prio alpha to zero on that same
set of hypers
and tell me if it drops performance,
that would be helpful.
Topol- topological
and geometric.
I don't know if there's like I don't
know what work in that space is like
legitimate and important to niche.
So, like if you read the if you read a
couple of his papers and you find it
interesting,
it's typically the way to go.
Okay, so
heavy prioritization
messes us up, right?
Buffer four or five, it doesn't matter,
Tim. So,
five is in dev anyways, um but
five is a very small change. You can
think of five as The goal of five is to
do something that's like the prioritized
replay in four, but much more powerful.
But we're basically we're having an
issue where like we're not seeing any
results because
buffer four is so powerful that it's
actually working without even
prioritized replay of any type.
So, that makes it impossible to test.
Hello, muffin.
See, I got confused by this because
look, all the good runs have high
alpha, right?
But that's so weird to me, right? Like
based on this curve
Now, something is weird. You would not
expect that you could just drop alpha to
zero and have it still work, right?
Like it's very clearly
heavy prioritization here.
Add state for five for smashing it.
Hold on.
Actually, I got to go look at the
formula.
Why am I typing OSRS, dumbass?
Much Runescape.
Okay, so alpha equals one is just
directly proportional
to uh the probs here.
So actually, one is not the most you
could do technically, right?
So wait, you can just set them both to
one, right?
Oops.
Like this.
Simple matches.
Uh so Tim is it's kind of different.
Hey, how's it doing, Cash?
Um
yeah, the implementation matches
[clears throat]
the paper, but like
uh it's not over historical data. The
Puffer 4 version of PER is just over the
samples in one buffer.
Yeah, so uh the thing that's going on
here, um
to give you a brief overview,
so we have this prioritized experience
replay thing. You can view this as a
form of implicit curriculum learning,
okay?
Because it takes your current data and
it prioritizes the data that has higher
signal, so it makes you more robust to
noise.
I remember that we tested this very
extensively in Puffer 3, and it was a
huge upgrade on some environments. And
in fact, uh when we compared it to
dedicated curriculum learning
algorithms, like we did this for a
client where just this thing alone was
as good as the other soda curriculum
learning algorithm.
Um go explore style type stuff should be
substantially more powerful because
instead of just dropping bad data, it
actively goes and gets you fresh new
good data
using state sets.
But the problem we're having is now
Puffer 4 is just so ludicrously good
that it's apparently solving everything
we throw at it without even needing the
implicit curriculum.
So
and like including tasks that I don't
understand how on earth it's even doing
that.
So, it's fine. We've got a full 2 weeks
for this allocated.
Um
I like I can kind of just take the time
to really understand what's happening
here.
And make sure that we get a good version
of this that makes sense, clean
baselines, figure out all the issues,
good benchmark ends, etc., etc.
It's really good. Yeah, the other thing
that we noticed So, I didn't realize
this until yesterday, but um it's been
using way longer horizon information.
Like uh we got a sweep with 512 optimal
horizon for mazes. That never happened
in Puffer 3 because long horizon
training was just slow.
And we even have an open PR by some
awesome CMU students that will make our
long uh horizon training specifically a
good 20% faster.
So, this is all good stuff in a way, but
it's it is very frustrating to not I
don't quite see how everything fits
together yet, and that bothers me given
that um you know, I've been trying so
hard for so long to make all this just
sane and consistent.
Yeah, uh that's kind of the thing with
four. Like
the core architecture is just better.
It stacks deeper.
It's automatically tuned for you.
And it's efficient for longer time
horizons.
Do we think it's meaningful?
Should I make this core task harder now
because
it's almost capping out?
Like what do we know here? So,
it works either with prioritization.
No, wait. Wait. So, that it works with
no prioritization.
It works with curricula basic
curriculum.
Um
it doesn't work with prioritization and
no correction term, it seems.
Bigger hidden? Yes, Tim.
It can pick both bigger and smaller
hidden, though.
So, I'm seeing some tasks that pick
smaller hidden, and then some tasks that
pick bigger hidden.
But like it's widening the range, and
that is intended.
Because both bigger and smaller networks
are more efficient on PPO 4
than it was than they were on PPO 3. So,
cuz PPO 4 for the big networks, you get
B float, right? And for small networks,
you have all the overhead reduction.
>> Yes, Tim.
That matches what I see on my new
sweeps.
Uh I don't You don't really need to mess
with it for five, Tim. If you get me
those initial results on four and you
say, "Hey, actually the prio act like
works and it it's actually meaningful
and you can't just drop alpha to zero
ever."
Like I can do the ports and stuff. It's
easy for me. It's like literally so
straightforward you can do it with
codex.
And the thing is the code changes are so
like unambiguous that there's basically
only one way to do it. So it doesn't
even mess anything up.
>> [sighs]
>> Hey Liberty.
Okay, see.
So this still works here.
If you set prior alpha to something
negative, it should down weight
high advantage data, right?
Okay, so this fails.
Which is good, right?
Are we vibe coding till death? No, we're
running experiments. We're not really
writing any code at all.
Okay. I'm basically just using this to
sanity check assumptions that I'm
making.
I build high-perf sims and I do
research.
We got a bunch of demos of my stuff on
puffer.ai.
Also demos of uh contributor's stuff.
AI qualifier
uh Monday stream 6 minutes in.
pufferlive.ai
It does run on iOS, doesn't it?
puffer It's puffer.ai.
Yeah, these do run on mobile. I think a
couple of the custom shaders are a
little iffy on some of the amps, but for
the most part it's good.
You receive message after me. Yeah, but
there's nothing I can really do about
that. So, that's because it goes through
Restream
and um
so, I'm on YouTube X and Twitch at the
same time
and it doesn't let me set the um
the latency options from there.
I do very much enjoy um
enjoy this.
Hey not a minute delay. I think it's
like 20 seconds.
Did I try both of these?
Explicit uniform state sets.
Yep.
The problem is now this is too easy,
right?
I mean all this means right is that the
uniform data is informative enough
somehow.
What's reinforcement learning? Uh
>> [laughter]
>> This is uh
So, I am a researcher in reinforcement
learning. This is interactive
intelligence training neural networks
that interact with simulators, games, um
like games, robotics, any form of
interactive sim that you like.
We do stuff finance, commerce, defense,
drones, whatever, driving.
And I stream all of my research live.
So, this is kind of one of the few
places where there is very deep
technical content done live.
We make a lot of core research
breakthroughs that affect the whole
field live on stream.
And uh we've got a bunch of contributors
that I chat with here as well.
Give feedback on things.
coralreef.json
Well, we don't want to go too crazy with
just we kind of already named too many
dumb things.
Yeah, so basically anything that I do
just solves this.
I mean, I guess we could verify, right?
If um
We have the incremental maze task that
we could play with. We could make that
randomized.
Okay, let's just say what if we just say
okay, the password task is super
sketchy, right?
Compiler design.
Well, you should probably have learned
this stuff if you have an exam tomorrow.
Um progress is okay. Things are There
are many questions
to answer.
I mean, the thing is the model of this
in my head is the Inferno, right? Like
the Inferno is the perfect task.
The thing that makes the Inferno perfect
is that there is reusable substructure
from earlier levels,
but then you add in new things.
Yeah, I think we'll try incremental
maze.
The incremental maze was a single maze.
We'll see if it makes a difference with
randomization.
That will be interesting. And if that
doesn't make sense, uh if that doesn't
work, then we'll basically assume like
you're not really introducing the need
for new behaviors by making the mazes
larger.
Incremental Sokoban.
Okay, that's nice, Tim.
That's probably a better test env.
I mean, I would believe it's it's very
likely that you could come up with some
useful stuff for for five with that.
Can I kind of ex- Let me kind of explain
what I think the problem is? So, the
problem is Puffer 4 is just ludicrously
good, okay?
And problems that used to need heavy
curriculum to work, they kind of just
work on their own now. So, you really
need environments where the only way
that you learn them efficiently is by
being able to get a data distribution
that's not what the environment gives
you normally.
Um I like to think of the Inferno as a
very obvious example of this
because
uh in the Inferno
you see new mechanics introduced at
different points in the levels, right?
You go through some levels and then you
see the blob, and then you go through
some levels, you see the ranger, you see
the or the mailer, the ranger, right?
And then the major, and then Jad. So,
you have to get through a lot of stuff
in order to see that, and it progresses.
You don't want to have to redo the whole
thing every time.
I could just use the Inferno, to be
fair, but
it's kind of a reasonably quick test.
If this doesn't work, I might just use
the Inferno.
This code I don't care about because
this is only this entire incremental
maze is only useful if this works for
this experiment.
Yeah, I think that in general, the idea
of curriculum, it has to be useful.
There's not a way that this isn't
useful.
Um
So, that's like a very, very powerful
thing to know, right? We're not just
guessing like, oh, I wonder if this is a
good idea. I know that this is a good
idea.
Okay.
Like a single play through.
Um
Maybe. So, the problem is like new end
complexity, right? You make a complex
new game and now you're using it for
fancy research.
So, complex new game has bugs
and
like you typically you want to use ends
in new research that you've had around
for a while. So, this incremental maze I
don't think fully breaks that because
this is essentially just a slight
remixing of an initial end that I have.
Well, it's might not be a bad thing that
40 doesn't solve it.
Like an incremental puzzle game is
perfect for this type of a thing, right?
Like your typical puzzle games where it
introduces a couple mechanics and then
it uses new mechanics and uses them in
new ways. That's like the perfect thing
for CL.
In theory at least.
I
makes no difference on Sokoban, really.
That would be consistent with my
finding, but that makes like that's very
[ __ ] up.
Yeah, so this needs to be like this.
Let's try this.
[ __ ] these stupid headers, man.
I don't know why my terminal does this.
Wait, which one is which, man?
Is the purple without the CL?
And sweeps optimized with hard
constraints.
So,
hard constraints, you have to prune.
It's a little trickier, but yes, you
can.
Oh, wait, hard constraints, not and
maybe I misread that, not just scalar M
score.
Reachability and dead placement
improvements.
Wait, hard constraints.
Not just scalar M score.
Well, what you would do is you'd mark
the run as a failure if hard constraints
are violated, yeah.
Purple is the setting you asked. Well,
that does make a difference in your
case, right?
Like, that looks like a difference to
me.
It's a small difference, but it's a
difference.
It's nowhere near what you would expect
though, I'd agree.
Okay, why is this not
Okay, this is only 24.
>> So, with prioritization versus
with no prioritization at all.
Okay, that's interesting. So, you do
have something at least.
Why did the big players not use RL in
self-driving, do you think, or very
sparingly? Because they have tons of
data.
And people are actually looking at RL
now.
Um, especially with Puffer Drive. Like,
there are now several companies that are
using Puffer Drive internally, including
bigger ones.
And we could make Puffer Drive way
better as well.
Be a good weekend project.
Hopefully, uh, if you've had it already,
your interview has gone well.
Inside it would it fit RL better?
Um I mean you can use RL for a lot of
stuff follow. If you check out some of
the papers from NYU on Puffer Drive.
Incremental Sokoban.
Uh I think I will end up looking at it
Tim, but I'm not quite ready yet cuz it
takes How long do the experiments take?
You can do it.
Wait, what?
Wanted to ask you these questions.
Sure.
Fire away. I will answer whatever.
And I will also attempt to indicate how
biased my answer is.
Wait, 23667.
It's like the exact same thing with or
without prioritized replay.
Save final or interval checkpoints per
trial.
Uh f-
I forget if we save checkpoints in
sweeps by default or not. There is an
interval flag. Yes. I think we do save
checkpoints on sweeps now.
I kind of forget.
But I will say that the the overall save
structure is much simpler than in three.
Cuz we don't have the janky-ass PyTorch
saves.
There's no way that this converges at
like the exact same solution for all
three of these basically, right?
Like okay, it converges very slightly
higher.
Very slightly.
I may as well launch that real quick.
issue
Yeah, where's the end when's the uh the
tower end the tower defense PR coming
muffin?
That'd be a nice end.
>> And now the trick is we don't want to
just get stuck waiting on this sweep all
day, right?
So we're going to just like have this in
the background.
And we're going to test other ideas in
parallel.
>> It's done.
Reachability dead placement
improvements. Wait, what do you mean on
a reachability or dead placement
improvements?
Maybe I'll solve this week. That'd be
good.
Make sure that this is live.
Yeah.
Cool.
And now
Because they're out of range from the
road.
But that's just solved by the sweep,
isn't it? Muffin.
Like a good policy will just learn to
not waste towers.
And it'll get higher score.
I don't even think you have to do
anything about that.
What design decisions are you proud of
with Puffer or gone wrong in the past?
The config system took like four
iterations of it to get it right. It's
like one of those ludicrously simple
things that there are a million ways to
make bloated and wrong and terrible.
Um
I tried like, you know, everything from
rigid Python schemas to YAMLs.
Um I had like this fancy class-based
thing at one point.
That just took a bunch of testing to
figure out what the least friction was.
And there was no reasonable way to
figure that out ahead of time, either.
It also was a big trade-off between like
what features do I actually want versus
how much blow does it worth to support
them?
And we ended up on something fairly
minimal with a like 20 or 30 line
loader.
Um let's see.
I think the
this in Well, in the latest puffer, I
think that the static build system,
although it's a little annoying for
swapping ends, it allows us to keep the
code a lot simpler.
And uh it makes everything very fast for
experiments on any given environment.
But I think that the way that we did the
compilation units was pretty good.
Um in fact, they're getting merged into
one unit, I think, in the next version,
but it's still pretty close.
Design decisions on the actual
architecture, let me think.
Man, there's a lot of stuff there.
I mean, I think a lot of the stuff that
I that went into
the blog post, right? Like the fact that
it's all static memory,
so you don't end up with OOM [ __ ]
halfway through training.
Um
That one was very nice. So, the way that
we make the way that we do all the
memory management up front is really
good.
A lot of the things that went wrong in
the past, I'll say, were just like us
fighting stupid Python libraries or
fighting around stupid torch
limitations. Like a lot of the gross
things, for instance, we have all this
really gross multi-discrete sampling
logic in torch because that op is just
irredeemably slow, and there's no way to
make it good without doing a bunch of
jank. It's actually pretty simple in
Puffer 4. Um
but in three like you just end up with a
bunch of Python jank cuz it's just
outside of Torch's programming model.
That's one good example.
Um
things I'm still not happy with, I'm
still not happy with how like how much
harder it is to do custom architectures
now.
Um since you do have all the static
memory management, you're just
responsible for a lot of things and that
makes it kind of tough to add in
custom architectures just with the
amount of different allocations or the
amount of different buffers of data I
should say that you're responsible for
setting up.
Um
I think it's very well worth it and
we'll iterate on that over time.
Uh I don't like the shitty VoidStar
based like extension system for this.
Uh I don't think that the C++
abstractions are the answer to it but I
still have to figure out what is the
answer to it.
Um
Let me think if there any other like
really cool design things. Oh yeah, the
Puffer the Puffer env is in particular
is so good. Like it's so dumb because
it's nothing, right? It's literally just
yeah, you have a pointer to obs and
stuff and a few other small things but
there's so many ways to just make it
bloated and stupid and if you look at
every single other RL library, they
found a way to make it bloated and
stupid. So
like not having that in some sense is
nice.
Bindings that were at the Python C API
was a [ __ ] nightmare. Just having it
be pure C now is so nice.
Um
but that bind system was already a
better like was already an improvement
from what we had before.
Yeah, separating out encoder decoder is
nice from um the core policy cuz you
basically always want the same core
policy and most of the time you want the
same decoder, and sometimes you want a
custom encoder.
Oh, yeah. I mean, I guess if we're
really reaching back, right? The whole
way that we do our vectorization, like
realizing that everybody was copying all
their data around redundantly five
times, and doing a bunch of shitty slow
Python. Like, the entire re-architecting
process of that over like three
generations of implementing that, um
that was really awesome. We ultimately
ended up making some pretty big changes,
but that aspect of it always stayed.
And it's like one of these things that
seems very obvious if you ask a systems
eng, but like when you go into it from
an AI background, and then you look at
all these libraries written by all these
well-known AI people, and they all do
things that from a systems perspec-
perspective are completely [ __ ]
stupid, it actually takes a huge huge
amount of work to get the stupid thing
like to still work into the format where
it's smart.
You know, it's very very different from
going to an existing well-implemented
systems thing, and making some
optimizations, right? Starting from
something that's just so bad off, cuz
you can't keep any individual piece of
it. Like, literally anything that you
keep, if you go to SB3, you can't even
keep a single piece of it. Every single
thing needs to be rewritten and thrown
away.
Uh two was Ocean Jess.
So, two was our first
low-level environment API.
That was the big thing there. We had
fast environments, and we got up to 1
mil SPS training.
>> Okay, these are all running.
Nice.
Now, it's funny like in retrospect, so
much of it seems easy, but just the
amount of work it took on every little
single thing is just crazy. And I guess
like in three, I looked back and it was
even more ridiculous cuz I basically
just had, you know, a Python torch
library that was a thousand X faster
than everyone else's and it's only
couple thousand lines of code. It's
like, really, was this that hard to
build? But yeah, it was. Um I guess it's
a little it's more obvious now with
four.
Like cuz we just replaced the whole
thing with CUDA.
But like a lot of the stuff we did was
pretty natural based on things that we'd
already come up with along the way. And
you kind of just get to see all the
transformation happen at once.
The only thing I think I'm not happy
with, I'm still very much not happy
with, is my own level of knowledge in
CUDA.
Um I need to get better at that so that
I can make our kernels fast and also not
gigantic horrible messes.
Like I need a better model mental model
of how much perf we should expect from
each optimization.
And um
you know, whether it's worth it or not.
So, I've talked to some uh I talked to a
very senior Nvidia engineer recently and
he told me that like even he doesn't
trust himself to know that at the moment
with how much the architectures are
constantly changing.
Like actually base CUDA on um
the older architectures feels very
approachable. Like that doesn't feel
like something that's particularly
difficult to learn, but then the fact
that the newer chip architectures are
changing so much fundamentally with how
you have to handle especially memory
bandwidth,
um
that makes it feel a lot more difficult
to know and to like have a good
assessment
of things.
The prioritization just straight doesn't
help.
I would expect that this comes up with a
dramatically better
solution.
Yeah, I would ex- I'm going to expect
that the sweep just find some crazy
[ __ ]
It's already up to 27, which is better
than we have now.
And only in four minutes less than four
minutes, 3 minutes 20 seconds.
Very, very low number of steps.
Big policy.
Hm.
We could also try the Inferno env to be
fair.
Oh yeah, Valo, did you do state sets for
the the Inferno?
We have Sokoban, but Sokoban has a
pretty small difference
with and without PR.
What am I doing? Reinforcement learning
research.
I uh I stream all the dev that I do.
We're currently trying to figure out
this new curriculum learning method, and
we're having a hard time with baselines
because our normal algorithm is just
solving everything.
What are state sets?
Uh setting the environment to a
particular state that you've seen
before.
So, basically being able to return uh
return the simulator exactly to anywhere
that you've been before.
The key insight is that since we're
implementing our own environments and
we're doing this across many domains,
um it's actually a quite easy thing to
build into almost any type of simulator
you can think of.
And
it should be wildly ridiculously
powerful. It should be.
But because our baseline algorithm has
gotten to be so strong now,
we're actually having a pretty big
difficulty seeing um
seeing it.
>> Yeah, so we have cool research going on
at the least.
Um
Muffin, warm starting doesn't really
work super well.
Like that's not a thing that we have
specked out with puffer. We could pretty
easily do it, but um
we don't restore the optimizer state.
Like we do not save the optimizer state
at the moment.
You'd have to save like learning rate
schedule, optimizer. You have There's
some additional stuff you have to do to
make that make sense.
Yeah, I don't buy that we're basically
getting the same score no matter what we
do. That's weird.
>> I'll try this and see if this makes
literally no difference as well.
7.4
Interestingly, this has become a much
harder task.
It would seem.
If this gets the same score, like I'm
not buying that no matter what we do, it
just has no effect.
You know?
I think there's got to be some wires
crossed.
>> What are your views on GPU drive?
We have puffer drive now.
We collaborated with them. There's a
much faster version of it now.
It's right on our website.
There's a 2.0 out now as well, and
hopefully we'll be finding some time to
help them port up to puffer 4 soon
because it could become even faster.
Got it.
Yeah.
Most of the places that you find the
really high perf Sims were already
involved in.
>> Okay, we'll have it go check on this.
Um, I'm going to use the restroom and do
a couple quick things. I will be right
back.
I think that like there's got to be some
wires crossed. I just do not believe
that
like any possible permutation if PER
does nothing. This was very, very
tested, so
I'll be back.
Huh.
It's actually having a tough time with
this one, isn't it?
What papers have you published?
So, most of my papers are from my PhD on
neural MMO, which is this massively
multi-agent environment.
Uh, where I came up with a lot of like
the end of techniques. What on earth is
it doing here?
Yeah, I don't know what it's doing here.
Um
I There is also there are a couple white
papers on pop or live, but I really
don't publish anymore. If you want to
read some of the stuff I've written
lately,
the best thing you can do is go to X uh
x.com/jsuarez
and check out my articles. I write lots
of articles there. Some of them are
opinion pieces, but some of them are
technical research reports. Some of them
are for beginners, some of them are
definitely not for beginners.
I guess sure, we can do this for now.
We'll get rid of this for sure.
Run a couple experiments with some extra
metrics.
We'll get some debug info out of this
thing.
Um and then
I guess we get some better hypers and
try uh playing around with the CL on
that.
And grew arch could have anything?
I don't see how Jess other than like the
architecture just being good enough that
it solves as much as it's like feasible
without CL. It should still do better
with it though.
This could that's from neural MMO.
That was like the little character from
neural MMO the old versions.
Yes crit but like there's not really
I submitted one I published one paper on
puffer 20 that one a best paper awarded
RLC.
There's really not much more incentive
for me to do more stuff like this.
It takes a lot of time and it takes a
lot of time away from actual core
development.
So,
I'd rather just build all this stuff,
open source this stuff, write about the
experiments in shorter and um
you know, shorter form that's not gated
behind a multi-month publication wait.
Oh.
It is starting to find better ones. Look
at this.
And this is actually without
without prior replay.
I have no idea what the hell this
discussion in the Discord is.
They're kind of just saying stuff. Going
to need some sleep.
Like the thing is most of the academic
cams are really easy cuz they're really
slow and they can't solve them cuz
they're slow so they make them easy.
Debug and then we will um we'll see from
here.
I also don't understand why this is
locked to the ceiling like this.
We should just be careful and
disciplined about this and make sure
that things are actually doing something
etc. Um
I don't understand how it is that
prioritization isn't doing anything.
I guess
the best hypothesis would be
I guess the best hypothesis would be like maybe we broke prioritized replay
like maybe we broke prioritized replay
silently in 4.0, but it was good enough
that it just worked without it.
>> I'm fairly confident in my earlier
prioritized replay experiments.
I guess then the two competing
hypotheses here right are either 4 0 is
so good that you no longer need
priority.
Actually, wait. We know that 4 0 is so
good that you can get like comparable
performance without priority.
Um
I So, I guess either it replaces it
somehow implicitly.
Or
or we broke prioritized replay somehow.
Um in the 4 0 port, right?
That would make sense. So, if we broke
prioritized replay,
wouldn't we still be seeing stuff from
state sets, though?
We would.
I might have to go to 3 0.
It's a pain in the ass.
Let me check a couple things and then
we'll probably have to try that.
>> I don't need to have the model run basic
experiments, dude. I know what
experiments to run.
It'll literally take longer than me just
doing it, Tim.
And possibly [ __ ] it up.
I guess the best explanation I can come
up with
is that the prioritization is not
actually prioritizing crap.
And that's what we're checking.
And like meanwhile, this thing has found
a 33 solve.
Wonder if I had um
Did I put an ablation in my article? I
probably didn't.
I have to be more rigorous
on the research side.
Yeah, so I remember I did this, right?
Where
like all the best solves are up here,
right?
Okay, so this matches that it was heavy
sampling, heavy correction.
We'll double-check this on three.
>> Yeah, so there is a um there is a bias
in here.
So it is prioritizing.
>> Okay, so we'll see what this does.
And we'll uh we'll just assume that we
probably have the beta bug.
So we'll set beta to one, alpha to zero.
And we will compare.
>> Propose beta bug. I think that that's
probably in um
buffer four only.
Yeah, it's in buffer four only. It was a
kernel thing. There's a quirk when you
set beta to exactly zero.
Which wouldn't have happened in any of
the sweep anyways.
What is this language? Is this um
Jonathan Blow's thing or is this
something else?
I mean, it's like I'm expecting C with a
couple little things based on what I'd
heard, and there's just a [ __ ] ton of
extra crazy syntax.
I know C is a very simple language, and
it's like in my mind it's missing very
little.
>> Okay, I see why this is a game. Like
this is a game dev thing, sure.
Okay, but like
don't write header files.
Like, okay, I'd be down with just C with
two-pass compilation, right?
Okay, this is kind of This is kind of
cool.
This is kind of cool, yep.
I can see that.
[ __ ]
Uh
Yeah, every time somebody comes up with
like a cool uh low-level but like new
things, it's they just go way, way, way,
way too far away from C. Like
C is pretty [ __ ] amazing as is.
Like okay, I agree the macro
preprocessor stuff is [ __ ] awful. The
single-pass compiler is a total pain in
the ass. But like
you can fix these things without
changing the rest of the damn syntax of
the language,
which is pretty damn good.
Meh.
Resounding meh.
Uh
that's just too heavy for my liking.
I mean, I'd want to hear the argument
for each of the things, right? Just like
Let me see. See where the two two-pass
compiler would be nice.
Um
that removes
a lot of the header junk.
Uh let's see. We would do
some of the stuff around making the
language less reliant on macros. Like,
okay, being able to run full functions
to populate stuff.
I mean, that's kind of nice, but also
you can just do that once on
initialization, can't you?
Maybe I just really like C. I don't
know.
There's mostly just some [ __ ] around
like compiler flags and what isn't isn't
undefined behavior and then the compiler
tool chain that could be streamlined
more than the language.
>> Actually, the one incredibly unpopular
take I will have is um
I would actually be down with C with uh
white space instead of braces. I
actually just do not like um
braces. Yes, occasionally you get a
spacing bug, but having to close like
three levels of braces and lose three
lines in between everything is such a
pain in the ass.
I don't know. I've heard okay things.
I've never written Go.
They have like Go example program.
Are you kidding me? They made it format
print out like
All right, we'll see if this makes a
difference.
Merge opportunities
custom M's.
Um, I mean, yeah, if you're good and you
like our stuff is all open source.
I would think we could pretty easily
sell services around stuff if it
weren't.
Since we don't want to do that, we
mostly do stuff around custom M's and
R&D.
Or like
R I I?
It's a good thing if it doesn't in my
mind.
And I guess in my mind like C is just
damn near perfect.
Wait, what?
Multi-line block comments.
That is nice. Yes, I will agree.
Some data types, I like that. Sure.
No implicit type conversions.
Uh
See, like there are little things in
here that are nice.
But then there's a huge amount of stuff
that's like, why?
>> Good. Good. Good. Good. Good.
Good.
The thing is this is not being a better
C.
This is way too different to like this
is way too much to be a better C.
And this is pretty much what I see with
every single one of these languages, you
know, including stuff like Zig.
They do way, way, way too much.
But hey, engineers are known to get
carried away, right?
Okay, this we have a pretty clear
difference so far.
We have a much clearer difference on
puffer um puffer three, it looks like.
Let's try something real quick.
Maybe not real quick. We'll see.
>> Which ends different memory
architectures.
The thing is like those kind of go hand
in hand, Noah.
We don't really consider partial
observability to be a problem.
Like partial observability is a problem
when coupled with stuff like memory.
At least like
it's not something that requires
specific algorithm algorithmic
consideration.
Being partially versus fully observed in
my mind.
Like I know you all palm DP versus MDP,
but like in practice doesn't matter.
Yeah, you literally have to train with
dash dash. I was pretty proud that I
came up with that.
You literally have to train with dash
dash slowly.
So that you fully understand what you're
doing, you know?
Well, Jess, we haven't even tried um
Ming Rue in Puffer 4. Like, we haven't
even tried the torch version in Puffer
4.
Right?
Oh, Jesus. 27 minutes. Yeah.
That's abysmal.
that in puffer 3, my my research in
puffer 3 was correct.
There was a large gap
purely from prioritized experience
replay.
And actually, if we look at this 84 to
91 thing,
if we just go to Whoops.
If we go to my X,
Okay, interestingly, it looks like we
had
um higher 90s in here, like a a higher
90 result.
So, it doesn't fully match what we had
back then.
We get 0.91.
But then,
a gap of a few percent,
that's about in the right ballpark, I
would say.
Now, we might have not shipped that
exact run because we might have chosen
one I think that we chose one that ran
in a reasonable amount of time,
which is why it's not the 90 like five
or whatever.
Near limit mode.
It makes me happy. I like this.
>> There's a fi- there's a a fallback crit.
You can use torch in four.
It's much slower.
Meanwhile, this thing has gone and found
39 hypers.
Now, this is using fire replay.
So, I guess what we'll do is if this
thing is if we get some good perams out
of this, we could just use these and see
if on the higher score version of this
if replay makes a difference or not.
Also, look, this [ __ ] isn't even [ __ ]
stable, right?
I guess we'll have to let this run.
But, I wouldn't be surprised if this
doesn't give us the same results. Like
this is really long horizon stuff and
torches numerics are terrible.
Drone multitask your view on task being
per end or per episode. They feel
equivalent to me. I do per episode fin
unless there's a very strong perf reason
not to do it that way.
Per episode is much easier to control.
Also for convenience, um assume that all
of the ends should have the same number
of drones.
There's some really obnoxious
infrastructure stuff that happens if it
doesn't work that way.
Let me see it what 92 mil was supposed
to be.
Okay, yeah. So, this thing is just bad,
right?
So, we actually So, we can try the
replacement trick.
And then we can also mess with we have
better hypers.
Potentially for the incremental maze at
least.
Two separate things to play with.
See, even if we wait for this, I'm not
going to be surprised if the results on
this are way worse.
Uh I think Finn, we're mostly finding
that stuff is jank.
The go explore
Like the the motivation behind
using state sets is strong enough that
it would take a lot of evidence to
convince me that this is not going to be
a major major improvement.
Like there are some tasks that should
pretty much be impossible to solve
efficiently without state sets.
Um
so I'm leaning towards more so we
probably
messed something up in Puffer 4
and then the base algorithm was just
good enough that we didn't notice.
What conclusion would you draw if you
are proven wrong?
I mean it would have to be something
crazy like RL is just like qualitatively
better.
Um
Like it would have to mean RL's better
at learning in some ways than people are
in like an area where it's widely
believed that RL is much worse.
It would basically mean that regardless
of the sample efficiency that takes to
get RL off the ground,
um
relative to that, learning hard or like
hard new things in a task later on that
share some substructure with the
original, it's it's like very efficient
at.
But even that wouldn't be enough. Like I
it's almost I don't see how it would be
possible for this thing to be wrong.
I would believe more so that there are
like
it may be the algorithm isn't quite
simple so simple. You know, maybe
there's a thing with integrating the
data in a way that doesn't bias training
that's kind of subtle and tough to get
right.
But
I mean it's
it basically means that RL doesn't get
better by being able to directly
practice the task the portion of the
task that it's currently worst at.
Yeah, this is at least training
something, I suppose.
This was uh
the original OpenAI task, right?
What did you do on all of it?
No, it's not exactly the same, Jess.
Like cuz the distribution is very
different. So like
it Okay, so prioritization not helping
over um a fixed data set
like that would be less surprising,
right? That'd be like, "Okay, maybe
there's a little bit of juice you can
squeeze out of it, but really not that
much. Just train on everything." Sure, I
buy that.
But, this is like you don't get to see
the piece of the the late piece of data
unless you do the early pieces correct.
Like, the analogy is a lot closer to
like you don't get your next piece of
language modeling data until you like
perfectly model the sequence up to that
token.
You know?
Like, treating the entire thing as one
long thing like one long thing to
predict.
And you don't get to train on the next
bit until you get the previous bit
right.
It's very different.
Okay, so it's found
See, this is the crazy thing. I just run
And like look, this one was using the
prio.
Oh, no. It isn't.
So, yeah. It's basically finding
solutions that don't require
prioritization
and only run for 3 minutes.
And they're just way better.
I mean, I think the best bet would be
that our prioritization's just broken,
right?
And then like that would mean that the
prioritization parameters that we found
don't really matter. So, then when I try
to go use those for a curriculum
it doesn't ma- it doesn't make a
difference.
Oh yeah, for folks watching
star puff her on GitHub, please.
It's absolutely free.
It helps us out a ton.
And you know, all the stuff I'm doing
here is free.
All the code I do is free.
Um but we do have to support this
project somehow.
And we do this by
building high-performance simulators for
companies.
And the more we see stars on GitHub uh
the more followers on Twitter the more
companies just contact me and I don't
have to spend my time on advertising and
I get to spend my time on core dev like
this.
And I really do not like advertising.
I like building things.
I like begrudgingly tolerate
doing enough things to run a company.
I mostly kind of just want to be
building stuff.
So high prio high
IS.
No, I you would think actually it would
be the opposite, Jess. If anything, you
should massively reduce the number of
samples required
uh without changing the amount of
compute per sample. So, you should make
You should just have dramatically better
everything.
Now, like I think that you should only
have somewhat better everything with
um prioritized replay
over the single epoch data. That should
be like a smaller boost.
And uh the state set should be a much
larger one. That's the expectation.
Now, obviously, we don't want to just
like keep
fiddling with stuff until we sort of
force the outcome that we want.
But
this is um
I mean, this one is well evidenced
enough that it would be very, very, very
weird
for this not to be the case.
Yeah, this is more than just intuition
though, right?
Intuition is like when researchers talk
about, "Oh, yeah, well, if we give the
model imagination, then it'll be able to
imagine this. So, we implemented this
thing and we called it imagination." And
it only vaguely represents imagination
and it sort of works in the way we do,
except then we run it on something else
and then it doesn't. Oh, well.
Like this is much more like, "Well,
there's absolutely no possible other way
to solve this task other than with this
method. We implement this method. It
doesn't seem to help. Mm, I think
something's wrong."
I think something's wrong with the way
the method is implemented.
Like the evidence for this, for
instance, like this is way, way, way
stronger evidence than something like
world models would be, for instance.
Like in fact, you would consider
something like this should be a
dramatically more powerful
um
should just be dramatically more
powerful than world models.
Yeah, so this is not like
last summer I had this on policy off
policy bridge thing I was working on
where I was trying to figure out whether
you could do semi off policy and like
smoothly scale computing data. And it
was kind of surprising to me that you
couldn't, but I think I found a pretty
good mathematical explanation for it,
and ultimately it makes sense. This is
like
many, many times stronger confidence
that this works than the thing from last
summer.
No, I think that I think the article
from the article I wrote
I no longer think that's a a avenue to
research at all.
I think the much, much more promising
version of this is what we're doing
here. In fact, like this should be
strictly stronger. Um than any
off-policy thing you can do, right? Cuz
the only reason to do off-policy
is like assuming you have good sims, the
only reason to do off-policy you got
lucky, you found some good data, and you
uh you want to make use of that good
data that you found. But like with this,
you can just go set the simulator state
back to right before you got that nice
piece of information, and you can just
keep running it from there and getting
fresh purely on-policy data.
So
this should just be better.
We'll have We'll let this finish.
Then we'll try this stuff, and if this
doesn't work, we'll come back to this
and do the other run.
But I don't think we're going to fully
recover perfect is the problem. I think
there's a gap just with the numerics of
torch.
Stuff like this, for instance, should
really benefit from curriculum.
What's this?
That's nothing.
Okay, 1 minute left on this.
And then we will do the next thing.
This is definitely too slow though. I
don't want to be running more 30-minute
experiments.
Particularly when we see that like the
torch numerics gap is going to screw us.
We already know what we get without it,
so we can skip that one.
So now we're operating at like such a
high
maximum.
I might have to make the max map size
bigger.
At least these experiments aren't awful
awful to run now.
But it is very clear, right? Like this
one here is not even using the prior
replay.
Maybe let's see.
Yeah, it's not even using the prior
replay here.
>> I'm going to go get my vitamins while
this runs. I'll be back in a few.
We're going to figure this out today.
I do not believe that prioritization is
just replaced by Puffer 4.
It's possible that we have a few bugs.
It's possible that we need harder tasks.
But there's no way that we just like,
"Oh yeah, you don't need curriculum when
RL gets good enough." I don't buy that.
I'll be back.
>> Okay.
I have more ideas.
I got more ideas.
We're not beaten.
We are not beaten.
Uh ooh, holy [ __ ]
That I think that might have done
something. Wait, 995.
Do you know what the easiest thing would
be to do?
Let's do it this way.
This is outlived its usefulness.
Um
47, 49,
51.
I don't want to make too many like
ridiculously hard things.
But
Cover feels like cheating with this
competition.
Yeah.
Hey man, if you can crush stuff with
Puffer, by all means, you know, give us
some shout-outs and stuff for the tech,
but
by all means, have fun.
If you want to do like a blog post and
stuff with uh
with Puffer, like that'd be cool.
I'm happy to help promote things like
this.
>> Yeah, 55 just might be making it too
tough.
Though, you know, this is actually
this would be a very good test for state
sets.
Let me see if this latches onto
anything. If not, we'll go back to 47.
And um what do we do?
I think we'll try 47 with a shorter
horizon, next.
The road of heuristic is blowing
everyone else out. Yeah.
That's funny.
Hey, if the environment looks like a um
a good one just like we can just end up
a using it as a uh a future test end.
If the environment end up actually being
cool.
I've got Spencer doing robo code right
now as a uh a self-play end.
Good to have more of those.
Self-play is very difficult to test
fully.
And games that have like some
interesting strategy space are tough to
find.
Did he get noted?
Oh, by a bot.
That's so funny.
We'll keep the task vanilla. That's
actually probably better.
The R robo code. Ooh.
Very nice, Spencer. That was quick.
Hopefully these params don't totally
suck.
I'm going to horizon 64. This is
expected to make [ __ ] way worse.
A 64
two mini batches.
We'll just run it and see what the hell
happens, you know? Who knows?
Maybe it learns, maybe it doesn't.
Adjusting total agents or mini batch
size.
Uh yeah, we're going to have to do
I think we're going to have to do if
we're going to increase
if we're going to decrease horizon
then we probably
2048, I would imagine.
Kind of guessing, kind of not.
It just gets something that trains in a
stable out of this place.
Okay, so this is annoying, but if this
gives us something, this should be a
substantially better test.
Cuz that would be an interesting one,
right? Like PER just gets worse with
longer horizon the way that we're
sampling at the moment.
And um
longer horizon is just more important
for mazes. Like that would actually make
sense.
Yeah, but the problem is see if if this
is not good enough to latch on and learn
I'm going to give this 3 minutes to see
if it's stable and if not, we'll make
the problem easier.
So that we can try with a shorter
horizon.
I just need a starting point to be able
to study this crap.
Yeah, okay. So
I think what we do for this
Let's
That should make it substantially
easier.
It's solving mazes. Um mazes of a random
size up to a maximum.
Um historically, this has been a very
good research task in that it's
relatively quick to train.
relatively
and um
good performance on this has been
indicative of good performance on a
variety of other tasks.
>> What are you testing on?
So, now what we're doing here, right?
So, I'm doing the research on mazes.
I'm trying to see if
Um we're doing various different
curriculum based methods.
I'm trying to see if I can see a large
difference in performance on mazes.
And if so, then I will test the
algorithmic changes on all the other
ends in PufferLib.
We have a very wide suite.
Um
but the most computationally effective
thing to do I can do is to like test on
this first during development.
I have a few ends like this. They kind
of appear a minute to them. Like I have
some really fast ends that are just
basically good for making sure that I
didn't break anything really core in the
algorithm.
I have some uh still pretty quick ends
like this that are generally pretty
indicative of whether stuff is going to
generalize. And then I have some slower
very high confidence ends where
basically when stuff works there, it
works everywhere everywhere.
>> This is very irritating.
Okay, you know what I could do here?
I think it's I think it's reasonable
to just get
If I filter out rather
hidden size
No, not hidden size.
Horizon
And let's say I set this to 64.
Let's do it this way. This will be way
better for testing.
reasonable vac settings
reasonable end settings
Got train settings. We got some prior in
here.
And then let's just get rid of all this
stuff.
And that will keep this.
It will keep that.
>> So this will now let us test whether
uh Horizon
is the thing that's screwing us up.
I'm going to have to go check out puffer
four, aren't I?
If this doesn't repro, I'm going to have
to go check out puffer four.
Actually, let's just start on that now.
Be quicker.
Yeah, so this not reproing on four would
be very weird.
Anything weird?
I don't even see anything weird in here.
Uh it's deterministic, but this is a
different machine.
Only deterministic on the same
CUDA
GPU architecture, etc., etc.
Comes a little different.
If this doesn't repro, I'm going go
check out a specific commit.
Yeah.
Um
Let me go check out
Okay, good.
This is getting to be more sane.
Here we're actually figuring things out.
So without prio, we completely collapse
this result.
I'm going to try one more as well.
I'm going to try one more and we're
going to make sure that this pattern
holds.
>> See, this is why this type of stuff
takes so long. You have to just be so
incredibly disciplined
with your tests.
It is so incredibly easy, even with a
decade plus of experience,
to just miss one little thing and then
everything's broken.
Going to solve it today.
We're going to solve it today.
We were going to understand
and fix the problem.
Current theory,
I bet it's based on horizon.
Either that or it's a straight bug, but
I think it's probably based on horizon.
So, to test this, this is now the second
config.
We're going to set prio alpha zero, prio
beta equals one. This effectively
disables all form of implicit curriculum
learning.
We're going to run this again.
We're going to see whether it does the
same
as before or whether there's a big drop
in perf.
Note that we don't require it to fully
crash. We just require that there be a
significant difference in performance.
If this gives us the same level of perf,
things get confusing.
Okay.
We are alive. Look at this. So,
if I do prio alpha
versus perf here,
these results,
I believe are strongly dependent on
prioritization.
what if I take this filter
What if I do it the other way? What if I
do like 128 and up?
Oh, yeah, there we go.
There's no dependence there.
It goes away.
I see.
Okay, let's see if we can repro this in
proper five real quick.
I think I just copied um
I think N of params changed is all that
happened. So, we can fix this.
So, let's do
num maps map size
Yeah, that's going to be it right here.
Okay, so we're going to just go here,
paste this.
Actually, we can just delete.
We can delete this.
Then we can delete everything down to
here.
We don't really need it.
And then we will take
Let's go grab the point from before, 64.
Um and let's just make sure that we get
uptime perf. Yep, this one.
And then we're going to go right here.
We're going to paste this here.
Boom.
So we changed the env param naming. So
that's what happened.
Hopefully this still now repros our
result cleanly.
We did change the environment a little
bit.
Ah.
Dummy.
That would have been bad.
Yeah, there you go.
Instantly.
Uh wait, did we
1.0?
Huh?
Oh, up length 64 is wrong, right?
Yeah, up length of 4 is wrong.
Okay, so all I have to do now, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Hang on.
Um
maze.
Oh, or did we break something actually?
It's a different architecture, isn't it?
Hm.
Oh, wait. I just had this running on
No, it's not a different architecture.
We had We This was swept on four.
It should be the same.
Okay, so now we can give this thing
thing.
Zaxxonics games?
Mm, don't think so.
Yeah, so this means we broke something.
It's just a bug.
I just wasn't careful enough.
It happens.
Huh.
That's very cool.
That's very nice.
Show me more of that.
That's garbage.
Spencer, hey. So, things are not
completely [ __ ] There is a bug. Um
on puffer four, I have confirmed that at
least for shorter horizon experiments,
PER makes a big difference.
I need to go rerun longer horizon ones,
but
um essentially, I think I just wasn't
careful enough in the implementation,
plus there are a couple conflating
variables,
and I should be able to have some better
results by the end of this afternoon, I
would expect.
You got a PR up for RoboCode?
Just pushing stuff, gotcha.
Cool.
Yeah, I'm um
so, I mean, just like I'm not really too
worried about the setbacks from
yesterday because
Okay, sure, whatever. Um I'm not too
worried
because like the states have to work.
There's no way it doesn't work. I just I
refuse to believe this doesn't work.
This is like many, many times more
confident than
pretty much anything else in any of the
other updates.
Like this is higher confidence than
MingRui was even.
Non-stupid easy obs.
Aim sweeps against stationary bots. All
right, very nice.
Does it look cool yet?
Can you just Can you just tell me if it
looks cool yet?
Base assets you left over were fine to
work with. Good.
Huh?
Uh yeah. Let me show you.
I mean, it's a shitty codex kernel.
So, this shitty codex kernel.
And then I think there's a reference.
Yeah, so it's basically this thing,
right?
So, the idea is that you have an obs for
yourself, you have an obs for everyone
else. You can cap them all together. You
do a linear and then a max.
And then for the actual encoder, you
want to do an additional fully connected
layer just normally.
So, then it would be, you know, concat,
fully connected down to dim 16, and then
this.
And I ran some pretty good tests, I
would say, as well to confirm that
stuff.
>> concat linear to dim 16 No, no, no, no.
It's concat linear to dim 16 and then a
fused linear max. It's linear to hidden
max.
fused
I tried like a a whole bunch of
different variants. That's the thing
that works and is fast. Nothing else
worked and just and was fast.
>> If this doesn't work, I'm going to go
check out a different branch.
This does restore the the speed though.
Okay, so broke it with that stupid
patch, lovely.
No, actually this is fine.
Okay, so we get 75.
we see if we repro the gap on buffer
four.
We just ran this experiment before,
though.
Okay, there could be other things wrong
with it, though, right?
Yeah, there could be other things wrong
with it.
Well,
we have to see how well we fix things,
right?
Man.
Screwy screwy, huh?
I trust the old version of the end of
more though.
We taught very clearly in the old
version of the end didn't we?
It doesn't even train out of the box in
this one.
What am I doing?
Live reinforcement learning research.
Currently we are trying to track down a
a discrepancy in a couple of curriculum
learning methods
so that I can actually run my proper
benchmarks on the new things I'm working
on.
What if it was just goal is three and
agent is six?
Okay, sure.
Why not?
>> Yep, exactly.
Um
I run Pepper AI, a small private lab.
All my research here is open source
though.
Um
We also do work professionally for a few
companies.
The majority of my time is spent just
doing core research,
um building high performance
infrastructure.
And I do most of that right here.
The key thing to realize though, right,
is
on the sweep from buffer four,
curriculum behavior is expected.
So, on the highest confidence version,
we're getting the expected result.
And on the screwy version, we're getting
screwy results. So,
that likely just means I messed
something up
rather than anything core with the
method.
Commit identities.
Sure.
Do whatever.
I'm sure I just made some dumb mistake,
right? Because
like how else would it not train on
four?
Unless there was some bug fix that I
didn't get into the end with that point.
I don't think that's the case though.
I mean, the expected behavior, right, is
that curriculum learning, implicit
curriculum learning, helps.
Um dropping implicit curriculum learning
hurts.
And states that should be much better.
There's this conflating variable of the
horizon,
where it seems like it's difficult to do
curriculum for long horizon segments.
We can isolate that out for now.
But I need some consistent results here.
We need stuff to be more consistent.
I don't know why it's doing this, but
okay.
Do you teach RL?
I make some educational materials.
Um
You just check X/JSuarez.
It's a combination of research posts.
Um some slightly more introductory
material.
Some um
other content just generally around RL
for the most part.
This could be the self-play thing,
honestly.
>> No, I don't know if it's that. Okay,
wait. So, this works?
I'm trying to think what else we would
do.
I'm going to give myself until like
2:30.
And then after that it's going to have
to be um
Yeah, this is fine. We could Yeah, this
is reverting it back to the original.
It's very odd though that that would
change anything.
We must have just broken something in
that then.
That's the only thing that makes sense.
Let's restore. Okay, we have ways to do
this.
Let me use the restroom real quick. And
um we have some relatively quick ways to
check this.
>> We'll see if this does it. If not, we
have um we have an out.
Let's see if we recover the earlier
experiment behavior.
>> What did we say this was before?
According to the the sweep.
Couple points lower than this, maybe.
If this matches.
Okay.
Uh
Why is this suddenly not dependent on
PER?
Wait.
No, these are the exact same numbers.
Hang on.
If it's still broken under PER, then we
just have to um
go back. But no, now it's training.
Now, it's training and it's better under
PER.
Cuz at least this is the result we'd
expect.
we try to replicate one of the longer
horizon runs next.
Actually, we should just take the um
the defaults, shouldn't we?
How did I get started in RL?
I started making a miniature MMO and
trying to get agents to train on it when
I was an undergrad and then I took it to
OpenAI and did research there.
I was already um
I was already uh in NLP and computer
vision.
I'd published like one small, well, not
too small. I published one thing.
And uh
you know, I had a decent enough
background in general deep learning and
ML.
And RL was kind of
uh it was relatively newer at the time.
Well, that would actually be it then,
right? If I
This is just a bad intermediate version.
All right. So, hang on. Maybe this stuff
is not so cursed after all, right?
Now, we'll see with this one if we
repro.
And uh, then we will see
>> [laughter]
>> Funny.
This is not expected to be 99 plus
percent.
That was with the other version of the
env.
I believe this is like 98 maybe, 97 98.
And then the main thing we have to ask
is whether prior replay makes a
difference here.
then it was just the stupid environment
diff.
If it doesn't make a difference here,
then there's also the horizon problem.
In which case we do our experiments on
shorter horizon initially with state
sets.
Yeah.
That's the play.
All right.
I have heard good things about the way
that um Go handles dependencies.
Like you do kind of just want to be
vendoring stuff a lot of the time.
I'm actually well
I am kind of tempted to just grab all of
uh raylib instead of having it in our
build path. Maybe that's better.
Diablo?
Uh whenever somebody hands me a very
fast version of Diablo.
But the thing is that wouldn't even be
that interesting like
except for the build stuff
like Diablo is not a very interesting
game to play.
The majority of that game is just hold
down the damn mouse button.
is a substantial drop in performance
without prioritized replay.
If we see no drop in performance or a
very small drop in performance,
it likely means that
the effect gets washed out
at long horizon.
And if this completely fails to train,
that's fine, too.
And if this somehow does better without
prioritized replay,
we get kind of confused.
But we tolerate it cuz we get a new
soda.
If it gets to like 99 plus,
we have to do our experiments on um
shorter horizon, which is actually
better anyways. Those are faster
experiments to run.
Rubik's Cube can be a good example.
Well,
it depends how you do it, I suppose.
What would that be good for? Um
It could be. Yeah, it could be.
There many different ways to do CL. I
don't know if it would be a good one for
this specific thing I'm trying now.
Okay, so let's mentally prepare here. If
this just does
If it does better like something's yank,
but if this does on par,
we just assume that the PER effect is
getting washed out, and then the hyper
parameters for PER basically mean
nothing.
And then that's reasonable because that
will have mean that we had a major
conflating variable in our test that we
weren't anticipating.
Then what do we do?
I guess we go back to the short tests,
short of horizon.
Make sure that we still have our s
PER gap.
We make sure the thing is state
settable. We try state sets.
Yeah, so there's going to be basically
no gap, right?
Possibly it even does better.
>> We have to see this one through and then
we'll we'll go to the next one.
We run experiments on the best horizon
equals 64 config.
We ensure
the quick test only take a couple
minutes.
We ensure that the
prioritization gap is as expected.
We try out state sets.
4.0
Uh yes, Weston, but like
it's a very small change on the end side
up to 4.0.
It's like a very very small change.
That was one of the nice things that I
managed to do is I managed to keep the
ends um
almost the same.
Need to PR it.
This sounds good.
I'm deep in 5.0 dev for this week and
next week.
I will check things. Okay, look. So,
this is nice.
There's a very small gap. It doesn't do
better at the least, which is good.
That's how things should work.
prioritization
doesn't really do anything for long
horizon.
And now we get to do 1-minute
experiments.
So, now we actually get to make progress
much more quickly now that we figured
out the stuff that needs the longer
experiments.
The first thing,
defaults,
they should closely match the previous
and the previous train run.
So, very nice. We can get
90s perf
in less than
uh in less than a minute.
Two. Okay.
prio alpha zero train dot prio beta
one
In fact, I wonder do we have um do we
have any of these runs that use 32
horizon?
We probably don't, right?
Yeah, so you can't actually do well at
all with 32.
So that's okay. We'll keep 64 as our min
horizon.
And there's still some head room in the
task
as well.
Okay, so this is good. We see not a
complete crash, but we see
a reasonable gap in performance with and
without prioritized replay.
What happens if we just have some
states?
>> I'm hoping that the results get to be
much more consistent now. We will see.
Okay, so it looks like what happens is
you take a small hit to perf
for using um state sets without any sort
of prioritization.
That's reasonable. That's very
reasonable.
Now, what happens if I heavily
prioritize these states?
This might be unstable. We will see.
Interesting. So, heavily prioritizing
the states doesn't seem to help at all.
Interesting.
Mhm, I don't really like the annealing
thing.
Mhm.
Doesn't really make big difference, does
it?
Okay, let's think about what makes these
two things not the same.
Well, also hang on. A warm up state is
1,000.
And then we have state buffer of 10,000.
This is 131
million steps.
How many M's?
2048.
You get 400 per step.
Maybe we shouldn't be.
Maybe we don't need this explore beta.
Let me try.
Let me try this heavier prioritization
with the bigger buffer now.
Which is in a sense one of the simplest
things you could do.
Just make sure. Let me make sure of
something real quick.
There's a bunch of seed variants, then
there's a big problem.
Yes, see prior replay is doing something
here.
For sure.
Huh.
That's a nice little progress update, 97
mining.
And 2.2k total.
Back to the side monitor it goes.
Expectation would be that this should be
able to match
at least match PER.
I think you need to correct for it, do
you?
Okay, so state stats
are still trailing um
H2 actually need
.8
.2
100 states
Um I mean, yes, technically, there are
lots of areas you could do things like
that.
But, Mu Lan wasn't just theoretical,
right? It was like practically tested
and tested very well.
Okay, so whatever PER is doing, we're
not getting the same thing out of state
sets.
Uh, I didn't overlook a question. If
it's not in the chat above me, I don't
see it.
But, I think something got dropped from
the chat.
No, RL's very, very efficient. Um, as
you can see, I'm running experiments in
1 minute on one GPU.
We run like thousands and uh, tens of
thousands of experiments every update.
We've got like 20 GPUs we run them on.
It's very efficient.
Mostly thanks to all the infrastructure
optimizations we make.
Okay, so this is closer.
But this is like it doesn't help perf.
So,
that's not great.
or maybe we just need to accentuate some
stuff.
Same.
I change the task.
The equivalent for puffer
uh
I mean there's lots of stuff in the
current algo that could be potentially
done, right?
>> Let's see what's the maximum size map
you get some signal on.
>> As the point of this is just to fix our
logs.
Um, it's not that you can't reproduce
OpenAIs Dota, it's that like
it would be millions of dollars of
compute
and a lot of infrastructure.
Okay, so this gets a little tiny bit of
signal here, right?
>> We go like this. We go like this.
We do 1K.
Ooh.
Tiny.
Okay, guys. These are the This is the
first sign of life that we have on the
curriculum and
This is the first legitimate sign of
life, I would say.
I do wonder what happens if we do this
now.
What's the curriculum? So, this is just
hard mazes basically.
Yeah.
It's just hard mazes.
Um so, like one obvious thing would be
like what if I just set this to 0.99?
In this case, we're no longer doing
randomized up to the size. The key thing
is we're just doing the fixed size.
I don't know why I didn't think of this
before. This is a much cleaner test.
This basically is just taking the
curriculum out of the maze problem.
>> Let's make sure that we actually just
cannot solve this any other way. So,
this is with a high exploration alpha
and no correction, right?
So, if I just do
Would this tiles change not break the
state space dimensions?
Cuz it's local, it's partial local
observations.
You just see a crop of tiles around you
regardless of the size of the maze.
>> I have a paper related to expand action
space in RL.
That's cool.
have a few games with really big action
spaces I suppose.
Chess is one of the main ones that's
really annoying for that reason.
Okay, so this should be kind of the
same, right?
Okay, so now you have a prior alpha of
0.99.
No annealing.
How's it remember which cells have been
visited? It has memory.
It's got Min Groot.
>> You can see here.
This is a very hard task.
It does occasionally get a little tiny
bit of signal though, right? Just a tiny
tiny little bit of signal.
I know the topic you're researching.
Yes, so this is currently curriculum
learning in reinforcement learning.
Um
we are specifically comparing
this implicit curriculum method from
Pufferfish
which does prioritized experience replay
over on policy data.
And a new state set based method in
Pufferfish that is based on Go-Explore
and allows you to directly return to
previously seen simulator states and
uses prioritized experience replay over
the states that are set.
Okay, so this one does not work, which
is good. Like cuz that's that's the
expectation, right?
The expectation this should not work.
You should not be able to do this task
uh on its own.
Ah, wait no. This is dumb.
This is bit.
Zero and yeah, you got to set this.
Otherwise, it has defaults. Okay, I just
messed up.
Parameters still valid.
This is significant.
Because this is essentially an
incredibly hard
um
an incredibly hard exploration problem.
And this is actually now that I'm
thinking about it, this is the best test
end of as well.
I hadn't seen I don't know why I didn't
realize this before. Had a good
suggestion on this.
Uh let me think.
What happens if you set this I think it
is actually I think prioritized
experience replay is well defined
for alpha over one.
Oh, yeah, it is.
Hm.
Prioritized experience replay is well
defined for alpha over one.
And this is now
this is 31 by 31 mazes
I set the map size to 31.
Not to forget.
I wonder what happens if you just crank
this to like five, does it blow up?
Okay, I think if you set it to five,
it'll literally only sample one state
ever.
But still, like this is a very good
result.
6 to 31.
So, it's randomly generated maps, but
there 8,000 of them and they're 31 by
31.
So, essentially, you know, a few of the
maps have somewhat easier path than
others just by dumb luck.
And if you just run a random policy on
them for a little bit,
you will get a couple lucky solves.
And from just a couple of lucky solves,
um this algorithm is able to learn.
It's actually pretty cool as well cuz
this is learning from a relatively short
horizon.
So, it's not even clear that it should
um
it should be able to do that.
Yeah,
we just we needed a different task.
This ended up being the correct task to
do research on this.
There were also a few bugs
and a few conflating variables.
But yeah, this is the task where it has
to work, right?
There's no curriculum anymore.
State sets. The way that we're solving
this is with state sets.
Once you get high value states,
you sample them aggressively,
And you start uh you start the agent
from those high value states or high
advantage high absolute advantage
states.
Is it pushed?
I can push it.
>> I don't know why I didn't remember this
task on my own.
It's honestly kind of embarrassing.
This is clearly what you would use right
to test.
I was so fixated on these like
long horizon you have to return tasks
that I didn't think of the much much
simpler to calibrate test case of just
problem with really sparse reward that
you only get a few times.
The task is randomly generated
fixed size mazes.
No, I gener- I had tested randomly
generated mazes up to a certain fixed
size, not a single size.
The problem is the randomly generated up
to a fixed size gives you enough
curriculum all on its own
that you don't see the result.
See, things like this make a very large
difference.
So,
I actually think
the thing to do should be
figuring out a way to make this buffer
smaller.
All right, I'm going to use the restroom
real quick and then we're going to
figure out
a more advanced version of this algo.
I'll be back.
There are two
two major issues
with the current algorithm.
Oh, let's let's actually just test it on
another seed real quick. That's probably
a good idea.
>> Okay, this is stable.
Two major issues. This is as much for
you guys as it is for the stupid bot.
Ooh, wait, we kind of do.
Mhm.
We don't want to store every state.
This is fair. This one is like
reasonable.
You could easily just do this as a
priority queue.
Mhm.
I mean that should work.
I'm going to let this thing hack on some
stuff cuz I want I don't even know if
this is reasonable yet. And then we'll
go iterate on the the implementation
because
like this is the type of thing where we
could slow stuff down a bunch.
Um I think that this does make more
sense though because otherwise like
sampling from a giant
million element buffer just sucks.
So, if we have like a 10K state buffer
instead,
that's probably better.
I didn't really take it much actually in
school, Jess.
I kind of learned most of it just like
in the uh
few months leading up to college.
Yeah.
Let's actually properly learn some
languages.
Uh I mean, I've been doing this for
how long now? 9 years?
I mean, I was in computer vision and
natural language processing before that.
And then, I mean, it was around the time
it was after AlphaGo,
right around the OpenAI 1v1s with Dota.
I'd already started on a big environment
project.
And
I honestly, I thought RL was going to be
the way forward for everything. And in
some ways, I still think that there's
another world in which it was.
And I still think that we're going to
get some pretty crazy stuff out of this
field that's not going to happen any
other way.
So,
you start something, you believe in it,
you have evidence for behind it, you
keep doing it.
It's funny, some of the things I wanted
to do back then are actually now
happening.
This is garbage code. Don't ever do
this.
>> I was about to open a PDF that somebody
sent me and then somebody said, "Please
don't open this on stream."
Uh, implement some stuff like
you know, implement some neural nets.
Learn some architectures.
Do a couple of projects.
Don't get bogged down by the massive
massive repos of stuff that are super
super slow and assume you have 10
trillion GPUs.
Uh, this is painful.
All right, I'm letting this do I The
only reason I'm letting this do this is
because this is like this idea might not
even work.
So, I want to just see if this idea
makes sense and then
like this is a this is a standard data
structure. It's just being implemented
in a nutty way.
>> Ugh.
Ooh, I think I know.
No, wait, let me think.
Uh Stanford undergrad and then PhD at
MIT, yes.
What may scores? We got 68% on um very
very sparse task
versus zero without.
I'm currently working on a a tweak to
the algorithm.
The override problem is going to be a
thing, though.
thing.
43 solved. It's a different problem,
though.
That one had a lot more scaffolding on
it. This one is 31 with no curriculum.
>> No, no, it's not even just no reward
shaping. So, none of these have reward
shaping, but before you get some short
levels that you could solve
uh in order to teach you how to solve
the hard levels, this is just the hard
levels from the start.
Like, you basically will get a few lucky
solves.
Uh so, you'll get the reward a few
times, and if you don't learn from that,
that's it. You get zero score.
>> How hard are you starting at?
31 by 31.
You basically you get to see the reward
once.
>> Keep in mind now, this is 67% of mazes
as well.
This is worse. Okay.
So, smaller buffer is a little worse.
What about bigger buffers? Is bigger
buffer worse?
I'm happy enough with this though for
now.
All right, here we go adding more
[ __ ] and complexity.
This should fix the thing where it
doesn't work with long horizons though.
Yay, more [ __ ] and complexity.
I'm going to have such a fun time
cleaning all this crap up, I'm sure.
>> We're going to probably just run a very
limited sweep to start.
>> So,
I'm trying to think if this should just
instantly improve perf.
I might need longer horizon to get
higher perf though.
>> I finally got the um the monthly plan.
I'm actually kind of shocked that it I
don't run out.
Um
The amount that they're subsidizing this
stuff is insane. Like I do not
understand how these guys are going to
make any money.
>> Yeah, I don't understand how they're on
track to be profitable.
Who is buying all of these [ __ ]
credits?
Like it's got to just be other AI
companies that also aren't profitable,
right?
Okay.
Not immediately better. It's actually a
bit worse.
Yeah, I'm going to I'm calling dot bomb
on that.
The amount of things I see with AI
shoehorned in where it just strictly
makes the thing garbage is very high.
It's literally like oh AI thermostat, AI
remote. And what was the other one? I
saw some really [ __ ] stupid thing
recently.
I mean it kind of tells you something
that the AI highlighter startup is not
the dumbest thing I've seen.
I think I should be more happy about
this honestly.
Like this solves a very long-standing
problem in RL.
Offer experience replay.
I mean if we make any changes to base
priority prioritize experience replay,
we should call it that.
>> I know, I guess I just I have a very
different mental model of the world and
where work actually gets done.
But that's not the same as where money
gets spent.
Like in my caricature diversion of the
world, you know, you go into a company
and like there's one guy in
you know, Power Ranger gear that's just
like super fast writing all the code
actually like you know, stacks of money
are just falling in around him doing all
the work. And then there's like 30
people standing around munching on
crayons and a few of them just like
shoving pool boxes of them up their
noses.
That's like my mental model of
>> Mhm.
Interesting.
Oh, wait. No, this will mess things up,
won't it?
Yeah, this will mess things up.
Hey, Muffin.
I mean, this is still a major problem
solved in RL today.
Right, this is still a major problem
solved, like full solved.
So, this is what I've called the
latching problem.
This has been a thing in RL forever.
Um the idea is that you have a really
hard task,
and you only get to see the reward once
or a handful of times by chance in like
any reasonable number of steps.
So, say, you know, you run 100 million
steps and you see the reward once.
>> Now the thing is in general
with your standard methods you just
can't. You can't learn off of one
sample.
Um there are methods that rely on like
deterministic
um they end up being deterministic and
stuff for that. But like in general you
can't learn that.
And in that case what you can simply do
is maybe 16, 32, 48, 64, however many
steps back
um from that state you're going to see a
high advantage.
You store the state.
And then you set the environment to that
state.
This can all be done fully generally.
And the result is that you're going to
end up automatically setting the agent
to be kind of near the goal.
And get further and further back.
You solve the latching problem
completely.
Uh working backwards arch is
not really the same.
Because then you're going backwards
conditioned on the action you've already
taken. That's a little sketchier.
High advantage states are specific to
each maze. Yep.
But you are able to put together general
patterns based on that.
>> You don't need to backtrack, Arch.
That's the cool thing.
Cuz that would be slow and annoying.
You can just directly set the high
advantage states.
Advantage is computed already
with this um advantage is already
computed over segments.
You'll automatically have states that
are far back. Like a bit farther back
from the actual reward.
General patterns. It's a maze, dude.
There is a general strategy for
exploring mazes.
And also, now it learns that it actually
has to once it sees the exit, it has to
get there.
It's not backtrack. The thing is
backtrack is something else and it's
very inefficient. There are algorithms
that do that.
I want to know how powerful this thing
is.
Does this learn anything?
In theory, it might.
You do have to get the score at least
once in order for it to learn anything.
Okay, let's give it a little Let's Let's
give it a little tiny bit of help. Um
I'll give it a little bit of help
because otherwise it just determinizes
too quickly.
Interesting. Why is this policy not get
the goal ever?
So, obviously the method doesn't work if
you never get the reward, but why would
this method never get the reward?
They are your local observations.
What if the exit is not in the
observations?
Well, then the maze is [ __ ]
impossible for anybody to do, right? You
wander around and there's no visible no
way to know when you're done.
No, state's not a vague thing with
continuous environments. State is
whatever that it's not I'm not using
state to mean observations here. I
literally mean whatever is currently the
data of the simulator.
Yeah, so this thing is like
determinizing super fast somehow.
Just stick the entropy up a little bit.
I think it will solve if it gets the
reward once.
Even with default hypers.
No, the model doesn't know the location
of the exit. It's just that if it's if
the if the exit is in the observation,
then it's denoted separately.
Okay, that was the uh the score.
Well, this is a very small model. Maybe
it lacks capacity.
Okay.
Maybe this was a little silly.
Let's try
I guess we can just leave this, huh?
Or sweep it.
>> I think we'll figure a couple more
things out and set up a sweep.
Why the [ __ ] did it add all of this
garbage and stupid [ __ ] model?
Jesus Christ, man.
I would just disable. I never want the
model to do these like gigantic ass
completions.
I don't know, some probably have more
on.
I think if they're not using it, there's
it's because they have um there's like
post training [ __ ] with their other
things they do.
Okay, so you get one reward
every 3.6 million agent steps.
That's pretty good.
That's a nice bound.
I probably left the sweep going, didn't
I?
44.
Yeah, okay. That's pretty nutty.
>> Mhm.
It works.
Now, the thing is
um
I fully expect the default config,
whoops.
The error scale.
Uh
I fully expect that the default config
is going to like
pull some [ __ ]
And uh find like some god
config.
It's probably just going to find like
some god config that solves it with no
CL.
But hopefully
we see a big difference and then we just
scale up the mazes, right? We just keep
scaling up the mazes.
And this should give us a pretty
convincing demo.
And then we'll get to refine it a little
bit.
hopefully we should see this on um
longer horizons now.
We'll see.
Hopefully this gives us at least
something interesting though.
>> I just want to get a sense of how much
harder it is.
>> Imagine that we get it to do uh the one
in one billion.
I would think realistically like no, you
can't.
35 by 35.
Interesting.
So, this is why I was wondering this,
right? If I just do
million steps
I do 35 by 35 mazes.
Why
certain steps are too hard?
Well, if you don't if you only ever see
the
If it takes you 30 What is it? 37
What is it? Um
Where is it?
37 million steps to see the reward once.
Like
Oh, holy [ __ ] Does this actually work?
Yeah, look. After it's one in 10
million, you see it a couple of times
and then you just latch on.
Okay.
Let's see. Maybe it's not too hard.
Maybe we just have the best algorithm
ever.
But like
this score here, right? You need to at
least get the reward once or twice.
And it's uh one in
Apparently it's one in 30 whatever
million. Okay, now this is something I
want to understand. Why does the entropy
crash?
Maybe it doesn't stop working
eventually. We'll see.
Cuz this is definitely not supposed to
happen.
>> I just want to see if this gives us a uh
reward
here.
Does this ever give us a reward?
this is just like on the edge of being
possible, I think.
>> See, it's actually it's optimizing out
the entropy a little bit now as well.
But I bet you that N core value is just
too big.
You know, it's just dominating the rest
of it.
Can I get away with 0.1 and not have it
determinize?
Okay, that was the first reward we just
got.
Memorizes the visited cells.
There are 8,000 mazes.
This is like you can probably still
train a model.
I wouldn't be surprised if you can train
a model with this on longer horizon.
Yeah, you probably need longer horizon
for this to work.
Cuz the maze itself just takes way more
than 64 steps to solve.
You are getting a little bit of learning
signal though. That's pretty cool.
That's like way better than random
there.
You see?
Cuz you're only supposed to get um
what is it like 10 or 12 rewards in the
entirety of training?
That's just like on the edge of
possibility, I'd say.
I think we're going to have this thing
solved.
>> model revisits.
No, it literally just gets a one if it
solves the maze. That's all it gets.
That's why it's hard.
And on average, it takes 37 million
steps to randomly solve the maze once.
So,
it's a [ __ ] ludicrously hard
exploration task.
>> All right, we're not going to solve this
today.
We're not going to solve this today.
We can solve 35
um by 35 maze. Let's try with the
entropy up, actually.
Okay, interesting. I think the entropy
bonus might be interfering with it.
It is still going to learn, though.
I'm going to try it with and without the
entropy.
Nine uh 10 million. So, one in 10
million.
One in 10 million chance to get the
reward.
And we can actually get a reasonable
solve, right?
This is to be clear. Look, you see the
episode length of this task?
All right, I think I'm going to be done
at at 5:00 today.
Getting early dinner.
8.4
I just want to see what happens without
this.
Is 15 too many discrete action bins on
angular rotation choice?
If you're saying for the whole circle,
then no.
Um
but like
if it's an angle adjustment, so it's
like you're turning relative a bit and
you're giving it 15 options, then yeah,
probably.
Also, Spencer
uh what happens if you have an
environment and you only get a reward
one in 10 million attempts? Like one in
10 million steps.
>> We had a few bugs.
I needed to make some adjustments and we
were using a um
a bad task for testing.
This is now
uh 35 by 35 sparse mazes with no smaller
scaffolding mazes.
Oh, this is also without re-sweeping
hypers at all or anything.
We're solving about half of the um
35 by 35s
in under 2 minutes of training.
So, 500 million steps means that you
would get the reward if you're running a
random policy, you get 50 rewards total.
Robocould scanning mechanism to populate
obs.
Yeah, it's a really cool task, right?
Why do we need the exploration to find
the first maze exit by random's chance?
Can't we bootstrap it?
The preset path.
So, the goal is not to just solve mazes,
right? This is a benchmark environment.
Um and right now so this this solves the
latching problem. The latching problem
is when you get a reward, but you don't
get it very often at all, how quickly
can you latch onto that reward and learn
something from this very sparse signal?
This does not solve the state
exploration problem.
Which is
given an environment with some number of
states that's very small relative to the
number of actions that you'd have to ex-
that that you would need to explore it
if you were purely being random.
Um
like how effectively can you explore it?
I didn't explain that well, but the idea
is that you should probably be able to
explore a maze proportional to n
squared, not proportional to exponent of
the path length.
No scaffolding mazes, exactly.
It's very funny because this seems like
a small change and it's like, oh yeah,
but you could solve the other task. No,
no, no, no, no. This is exponentially
harder.
You have good algorithms for that for um
for state exploration? No, we don't at
all. There are none.
Scaffolding mazes? Scaffolding mazes
means that instead of solving just 35 by
35 mazes, the training set will include
some 11 by 11, some 5 by 5, some 15 by
15, some 25 by 25s, right? You have some
easier mazes that give you some starting
signal.
That is the original version of the maze
task. The original maze task was
randomly generated mazes from sizes, I
believe, like 5 by 5 or something, some
tiny size all the way up to 47 by 47.
Uh for reference, you will never solve
47 by 47.
Rough estimate cuz I don't think you'll
actually ever get a reward.
Inferno solves when?
Yeah, so Valo should be done with his
interview today.
able to explain it much better than I
ever could. Uh, it's not verifiable.
Okay, 140 to 160 million steps per
random solve. So, um
Yeah, the fact that we ever solve these
at all with the scaffolding just kind of
shows you how crazy the uh curriculum
learning can be. Because otherwise, like
in the time that we run the experiments,
you won't get a single solve by random
chance.
So, assuming you don't have a better
method of state exploration than all of
the RL algorithms out there,
uh you just never solve this.
And it also gives you a uh a sense of
the problem scaling. So, 35 by 35 is 1
in 10 million. 47 by 47 is 150 million.
We could potentially prune.
We could probably prune some of the
budgets on stuff, maybe.
Mhm.
No, but that wouldn't help that much.
Uh I have a couple that's part of an
active collaboration.
But generally, mhm, not really.
Like I don't have any that don't involve
spending extra compute, at least.
Uh I kind of want to relaunch this with
35 by 35s.
Yeah, just that's going to be a bigger
thing.
Data exploration Oh, yeah, there's lots
of study, but from what I've seen it's
all [ __ ]
>> What maze problems are exponentially
harder than others?
Yeah, so the idea is
um
So, the idea is that if you get no
reward, right? If you're If you get no
reward until you solve the maze,
then you will get reward 1 / the average
number of steps it takes to solve a maze
on random exploration, right?
You can test this. You can test this by
running a random policy on the maze
or on like these mazes and seeing how
often you solve it on average.
So,
for 31 by 31,
uh it is on average one in about 3
million steps, 3.6 million steps.
For 35 by 35,
one in 9.6 million steps.
41 by 41 is one in 37 million steps.
So,
um this is very good to test how quickly
your algorithm is able to latch onto a
reward signal.
This type of thing is incredibly,
incredibly difficult for your standard
RL algorithm
because over the whole course of
training,
you know, they're only going to see this
reward a few times.
And then they have to learn something
based on that.
With the state set algorithm though,
as soon as you get the reward,
you will trigger a high advantage
estimate, right?
Cuz you expected to get no reward cuz
all you've ever seen is no reward, you
get a big reward, you have a big
advantage estimate.
You can use this to automatically save
a bunch of the states leading up to
getting the reward,
store them in a buffer, and then you can
sample those as starting states.
This is fully general. I'm not
exploiting any property whatsoever of
the maze, of the reward structure, fully
fully general. It doesn't need to be
deterministic, nothing.
And then essentially you get yourself
some very nice start states that are
close to a reward.
Maybe you don't get the reward every
time from the same start states, right?
But like it's a way easier exploration
problem now.
And then once you get some more rewards,
you can put those into the buffer and it
accumulates very quickly from there.
Um so this is I like I believe this is a
major breakthrough
because this latching problem has
plagued me for years. I have never had a
way to solve this problem ever.
Now look, as Puffer has gotten better,
it's been able to solve harder and
harder exploration problems.
Um but this is a very large jump, I
think. I think this is a very large
jump. I'm not going to know whether this
is a very large jump until I fully go
run some sweeps.
I think it would be very very surprising
though if you can solve this with any
other method, particularly because I'm
going to start sweeping this up a little
bit.
And um
you know, I'm going to start sweeping
this upwards and we're going to see what
the hardest one you can solve is with
the new curriculum method with better
parameters and then we'll see the same
thing for the standard algorithm.
You're basically just sampling states
that have high advantage.
And then you're setting the state of
some of your environments to those
samples.
So, it's funny that like this can kind
of do a search implicitly,
but this is not a search method.
Well, Jess, we have we have 35 by 35
mazes solving
with no curriculum. I mean, not no
curriculum, no um
no like smaller mazes in there, just
with the state set algorithm.
35 by 35 mazes, it's 1 in 10 million to
get a reward by random chance.
Uh people don't call it the latching
problem. That's my name for it. People
don't have a good like a common name for
it.
Curricula parameters swept as well. They
will be swept right now.
Uh the curriculum code is currently a
disaster.
This was all done very quickly
because over the last couple days, I
thought I had something really good day
one, and then I swept stuff, and the
Puffer 4 base algorithm actually did
just as well. Uh we ended up with a few
bugs and various things as well. So, I
had to do a ton a ton a ton of testing
today to fix all this stuff.
But now this is solid. Like this works.
Okay, I'm going to call it a day here,
guys. Um thank you very much for tuning
in.
Um I'm going to go grab an early dinner.
This has been good progress. I'll see
about this week tomorrow.
Uh if you're interested in my stuff
generally, just check out puffer.ai.
Star the puffer on GitHub, it helps me
out a ton.
You can join Discord to get involved.